all right in just a few days kids are
already ready aren't they CCSD spring
break and just in time Cowabunga Bay is
opening in Henderson terrifyingly Brian
will is at the park now allegedly in his
shoes look at that he's ready ready for
spring break as well Brian good morning
to you
good morning guys yes we are kicking
things off here pool season is just a
few days away and the general manager of
the water park is joining me now Kate
he's going to talk you through what's
going on in the next few days as they
open as I check out the water behind me
all right good luck well we're excited
to uh to say that we've got our blood
drive coming up tomorrow from 10 a.m to
4 P.M guests who can do our guests who
are donating blood will also get a free
ticket into the water park which is uh
fantastic they can use at any time
during the entire 2023 season we're
kicking off summer which means we're
kicking off a hiring season we hire over
a thousand individuals to help fill
specific roles and various spots from
lifeguarding to admissions to food and
beverage to uh Admissions and we're
excited to fill those roles we also have
spring break come up which we're also
excited about and we're ready to kick
things off with over 20 attractions and
a million gallons of water
Brian I think we all want to know how
does that water feel you know it wasn't
as cold as I was expecting the sun's out
now so not bad but I would wait and tell
what Cherry says when it gets into the
70s to take a dip I'm gonna get warm and
meet you guys back in the warm Studio
but all the Spring Break Stuff will be
on our website at 8newsnow.com wow Brian
I were impressed and uh shout out to you
for taking the plunge I think we're
gonna have a remix of him running out of
the water with the Baywatch theme or
something like that a true midwesterner
he got into the water and it's uh what
42 degrees there you go buddy go warm up
buddy go warm up 6 47